[Music]
let's go to jenny in oregon what's up
jenny
hey john how's it going i'm i'm
recovering
and you sounds like it
oh i haven't had those questions yet
mine's only nine months old so
i'll get there listen it's so great i
wish you'd seen it
in our house we talked about that all
the time i guess you just never
put five and five together
and anyway the follow-up question was do
y'all just stare at each other it was a
whole i mean she just went down the
rabbit hole for a minute so anyway well
good luck with that enjoy these these
silent years while you have them
right so what's up well my question is
my question for you today
uh my husband and i are actually
expecting our second in october congrats
thank you um
and we're both struggling with a little
bit of
gender disappointment we we both were
really hoping for a little girl
and while we are excited we are having
another little boy and so i'm trying to
really figure out how to
navigate that uh both my husband and i
unfortunately he's at work right now so
i'm kind of speaking for the both of us
as far as that goes but we're just we're
needing some help because we're really
kind of struggling emotionally so um
this sounds deeper than just
traditional disappointment or just
bummed out so
it sounds like there's another layer to
this talk to me about that
oh i'm sure that probably is um
so we found out last
let's see last monday we found out we
were having a little boy and i slept on
it and i did
i'm actually better with it and i'm
really starting to lean more towards
excitement and the idea that
our kids are going to be 15 months apart
so they'll have you know they'll be
little brothers they'll be able to
wrestle together play that kind of thing
and there's going to be pee everywhere
there is everywhere you know fantastic
that's right okay so you you you
you just described the perfect
we're disappointed our hearts kind of
dropped and at the same time
no this is gonna be amazing right so
and then you've begun to actually create
a new picture of what this is gonna look
like
right so i have um and i'm starting to
you know but it it creeps the
disappointment from me personally creeps
back up a little bit
when
like
i'm doing some grocery shopping or i'm
at walmart grabbing whatever
and i see a little dress or i see
something that's more specific to a
little girl moment that at least i know
with this second little
we're not gonna get the original plan
was to
hard stop at two and be done
yeah have seven
i have seven
yeah
uh yeah let's go with a no on that one
okay so
to in
is your husband taking this hard
he is and i'm a little more concerned on
his end of things than i
probably should be just because i love
him and i want him to open up and i want
him to
to have to feel like he has a safe space
to discuss things um if he wants to i
tried to have a conversation with him or
rather i tried to open the door to have
the conversation with him about this
gender disappointment because he
actually
admitted to me that he was going to be
disappointed before we knew what the
gender was he admitted to me that he was
going to be disappointed if it was a
little boy
we went on a road trip this past weekend
and i my first question to him was do
you have the capacity to
discuss
gender disappointment on this trip he
said he hadn't really
even had a chance to
process it yet
my husband's really good at
kind of just pushing it back
and not processing it
and it's
i mean i do it too by all means
i've just learned over the past couple
of years through my counseling how to
process it a little sooner and and go
from there and i'm a little concerned
that he's not going
to be able to process it the way that he
needs to and i just don't want him to
hold on to that disappointment
and i don't want it to sneak up on me
either every time i see a cute little
pink dress all right
so
a couple a couple of things here one is
um he's lucky to have you
and i would well let me back out so
ultimately here you guys created a
picture
that um pictures the positive way i can
say this okay and then i'll give you the
negative in a second
you created a picture of a life that had
a little boy and a little girl in it
right and
suddenly you start to dress that picture
up figuratively and literally right you
put clothes on that picture you put
little adventures on that picture you
put hugs on that picture all those
things
and then if you're like me you can i can
fast forward 20 years real fast right
like me i'm gonna sweat the guy out at
prom and i'm gonna all those things like
that happen right i can i can go away
yeah husband was picturing cleaning the
guns
yeah all that fun stuff right so we can
do that
um
the not nice way to say that is y'all
created a fantasy
that wasn't real and now
what you have permission to do if
permission granting is something i can
do on a podcast you're allowed to be sad
about it just be sad about it like we
thought it was gonna look like this and
it's not and we're actually it's gonna
sound like a harsh word we're gonna
grieve it
we're going to
openly state outside state out loud we
wanted this to be the case and it's not
if you don't your body will continue to
try to solve for that picture that
original picture that you painted
together
and the person who will bear the weight
of that will be your new baby boy your
son
right and that's what i'm worried about
so here's a couple of things
these were the plans were a fantasy but
they were plans nonetheless so what i
want you all to do is
this idea like well i haven't really
processed it yet you're not going to
unless you start speaking about it
though you've heard me say a million
times grief demands a witness you got to
say it out loud in front of somebody
else
and so i would love for you to and this
is going to sound ridiculous this isn't
a funeral
but i would love for you all to have
some sort of marker ceremony where you
speak out loud
even if it starts with you telling him
hey i talked to this guy and he said
we're allowed to be sad for a minute
we're allowed to be bummed out about it
and by the way you might be 25 um
your son might be 25
and you walk and see a girl in a cute
dress
and you're like i never had a daughter
that might always be there it's not a
bad thing you don't need to avoid that
by trying to avoid it you're gonna end
up cutting yourself off from your
friends that have little girls you're
gonna end up being annoyed when your son
brings home a little girl and wondering
why right so acknowledge it yeah man
that would have been awesome i don't
have that
and then be on about your day you hear
what i'm saying
i would love for you to have some sort
of ceremony that says all right we're
gonna go on a road trip together we're
gonna get some time together we're gonna
sit down and be honest with each other
about how we feel this thing hurts this
is hard i had a picture of this
and then in short order and this is
important you all have to be about
making a new picture with this little
boy in it like you're doing and you got
to do that together
okay and i would push him on this your
husband until he tells you the words i
can't handle this right now please stop
i would say i want to have this
conversation
and i you go first setting the rules
we're allowed to say that we're sad
we're allowed to say we're pissed off
we're allowed to say we're frustrated
we're allowed to be upset at our little
boy for not being what we wanted we were
allowed to do that and then we're going
to put a pin at the end we're going to
put a period in that sentence and then
we're going to start writing something
new is that fair
yeah absolutely cool
uh one other thing
i would stop using the phrase gender
disappointment
here's why okay it sounds really close
to some sort of diagnostic
like i've got anxiety i've got
depression we are together we have
gender disappointment as though this
thing is happening to you
does that make sense
yeah i would rather it be less of a
thing like less of a pinstagram or
instagram
an instagram or pinteresty kind of word
i'd rather just be yeah we're super
bummed out
and when you say we're super bummed out
we're choosing to be sad for a season
your body takes ownership of that you
take ownership of that and it's not some
thing that's descending upon you like i
have a thing no you don't you're just
sad man i'm bummed out i want to have a
daughter and i have a son now
and
uh
i wanted my kids in the order like i i
had drew it up that way and i got lucky
but i will tell you my heart was beaten
when when my we went to the first
sonogram with my son like is this good
like right so i'd kind of built it up
and i and i was like and it worked out
for me it ended up that we rolled the
dice and it worked out well and
sometimes it doesn't so i think it's
just owning that and then saying okay
here's what comes next but um if you
please please do me one favor don't feel
guilty about being sad is that cool
yeah absolutely have you felt that
i have um
it's more of i'm assuming it ends up
being the same but it's more of
i'm afraid that i'm gonna
treat this pregnancy differently or the
you know the outcome
differently because i secretly wanted
or not so secretly wanted a girl versus
a boy and i know that that's not fair to
my unborn son i want to give him every
opportunity
that
my first son charlie
has and had yeah and i think you will i
i think the important thing is to shift
the disappointment towards the fantasy
towards the picture y'all had not
towards the kid
and that's that's the marker there so we
had this picture it's not gonna happen
i'm gonna be bummed out about that
and now we're gonna create something new
and i'm gonna look at this little
knucklehead and just be
completely in love with this ball of
chaos that's coming our way
um but again all that starts with being
honest with yourself saying it out loud
owning it and then being able to say
okay what comes next what are we going
to do next but man jenny for whatever
it's worth you're right where you need
to be and your both little boys are
going to be lucky to have you and your
husband's lucky to have you
um let me know when uh he's born send us
a photo i can't wait to can't wait to
cheer you on man